Are you,
I did a lot of counseling work with people who were coaching work,
I guess with people who were fairly spectacularly successful and they were
usually workaholics,
you know,
they're the sort of people that were like,
they'd work 80 hours a week just nonstop.
That's just what they were like.
And one of the things we were always trying to figure out was,
well,
how much should you work?
Because one answers you'd just work til you die,
right?
I mean he just exhaust yourself.
And while that's not,
that's not a good idea.
And then you have to figure out why that isn't a good idea.
It's gotta be something like this is that you don't want to do so much work that
the amount of work you do interferes with the amount of work that you could
still do.
Right?
Because if you work like mad for two weeks and then you,
you like,
you have to lie in a hospital bed for a month,
that obviously isn't very productive.
So you have to figure out how much you can work diligently and then how much you
have to recuperate so that you can get back up and work again.
And you know,
that's,
people have basically settled on something like this and given it the divine
imprimatur that that's one way of thinking about it,
which is well,
you can toil away for six days and no wonder because you have to work,
but you should rest at least one day out of seven because otherwise,
well you don't appreciate life.
That might be part of it.
And plus I think it's more a matter of iterative interability you know,
because one of the things that defines morality is the capacity to repeat
something,
right?
So if something is properly structured in a moral manner,
then you can do it over and over and over again without any degeneration.
And so that's kind of like a relationship.
If your relationship isn't negotiated,
you can continue to negotiate it and then you can have a relationship that lasts
for a long time.
You can do it today and next week and next month,
the next year.
You could maintain it across time.
And this,
I would say is the wisdom that's been associate that's been garnered over God
only knows what period of time to say,
well,
look,
I mean,
even God needed to take a break and appreciate what was going on and it's not
such a bad thing for people to follow that,
that pattern.
That's a good thing for modern people to know because we seem to be,
even though you know,
we're very wealthy by historical standards,
our capacity to relax isn't exactly what it could be.
And I think that's really hard on people.